we have got sitting right here as Jim
Kelly has departed he is now inside the
luncheon room down the hall from us
where not only is there a big luncheon
going on there's an open bar that was
yesterday on that Hall anything no I
don't know if we can bring to get
something up do you think before we get
to our guests here do you think that Jim
Kelly's drink was leaded or unleaded
it's very lasting so yeah so Jim is now
in the luncheon room and joining us
right here are the two men who called
the Hall of Fame game last night on NBC
the voices of Sunday Night Football in
America Al Michaels and Cris
Collinsworth together good to see you
guys together again what up your voice
sounds unbelievable there's like you're
like the voice of God your life thank
you hundreds are here we go why thank
you Chris are very easy I had the ice
cube can I don't know Abby's know I
don't know jay-z who has those laughter
drink doc doctor dude I gotta get your
other ways write up your logo is the
best what I risk your logo you just put
your you running on the side of some
yeah there it is it's on it's on the
other my cube it's right there in front
of you you guys how many interviews do
you guys do together this is just a
rarity that the two you guys sit down
and do this has never happened before
are you serious knowledge I take down a
rubella or Country Club now you're doing
it oh that will be out there next to you
mate oh if there's a lord in the golf
heaven I don't look forward to that
problem I'm available anytime you're not
actually you're not your interview
tonight nah I got a post O'Connor you
take my role like a dick thanks fun good
to see you guys
what do you think of when you see all
these guys walking around here al I mean
you you called many of these people's
careers who walk around a goal Jack it's
pretty amazing it's almost like you know
you're a kid when you have the bubblegum
cards and they all come to life yeah you
we've seen all of these guys for so many
years and it's funny even though some of
them you haven't seen for 20-25 years
you immediately recognize them when they
when they walk by and know their body
shape has changed obviously through
through the years and they look you know
25 30 years older but they look good and
you know it's what what impresses me the
most is how excited they are how a
boolean they are B's they all come here
they get together
and it's spectacular and that's why I
think so many of them come back every
year to be a part of getting back
together with a group of people who are
obviously extremely special and what do
you think Chris when you can stroll
around I associate immediately place
that I remember from those guys you know
moments like which anyone in particular
on Kenny Easley last night and we so
Kinney easily there was a play we played
on opening day one time and boomer threw
me a pass right over the middle they
blew the coverage so I'm sitting there
literally by myself I turn around and
sort of do this little dance like Oh
nobody hears a heavy I'm going to run so
I take off and go running and Eddie
Brown was deeper on the route and he
starts coming back towards the line of
scrimmage and Kenny Easley was chasing
me he was the only one left that was
going to catch him I'm a scorer an
80-yard touchdown never scored an 80
yard touchdown before in my life and so
I'm taking off and and Eddie Brown
shoots about waist-high
at Kenny easily took like throw block
Adam Easley does this Reynaldo Nehemiah
hurdle over Eddie Brown never break
stride and catches me on the 9 yard line
just as easily as and it gets up like it
was nothing I'm like that's the greatest
football player and I was involved I got
enough was unbelievable I've got Cris
Collinsworth and Al Michaels sitting
here on the Rich Eisen show studio and
then you know tonight with the jacket
dinner and you see all the returning
Hall of Famers Jim Brown is going to be
here and he is the guy who is the most
tenured returning Hall of Fame member
from the class of 1971 that's that we
are going to see tonight it's always
great to see him here in in the state of
Ohio do you have any good Jim Brown
story from the Al Michaels rolodex from
back in the day well at all I got to see
him play live a couple of times too and
then I actually wound up having dinner
with him about three months ago Bob
Costas was out in LA and you know bob
has the obvious Syracuse connection so
it was great and what impresses me most
I mean Jim has been
very active on a lot of different fronts
through the years and I have tremendous
respect for the man he's so sharp as a
tack and he's a guy who you know you
look at his career he could have gotten
longer too I mean that was pretty
spectacular they're talking about
Terrell Davis and you know his career
was truncated by the injury you know you
think about Gale Sayers of course same
thing you know Sandy Koufax in baseball
you know Jim Brown could have gone a lot
longer than he did but amazing what
would he what he did and what he's done
in the afterlife is is something very
special
yeah he said that he just one day
realized instead of playing football
like here's your coat mr. Brown here's
your car mr. brown and then that's
Raquel Welch in the corner is when he
said you know that he just decided that
that was the end of that the end of all
that people that you played with are
here in this Hall of Fame as well Chris
Orr what do you think of when you see
these guys who you have done battle with
not just against as you mentioned there
well Anthony Munoz is the first one that
always comes to my mind and he's the
only player for the Cincinnati Bengals
in the Hall of Fame which is pretty
amazing so I'll campaign for Kenny
Anderson again but you know whatever
but Anthony Munoz he had a nickname that
I thought was the greatest nickname I've
ever heard he was called the eraser and
I'll tell you why because they would get
up Jim McNally our offensive line coach
great offensive line coach would get up
and he would draw the running game you
know back in the days on the chalkboard
so we're doing all the stuff and
literally this is how we game planned
every week so he would draw up the
blocking schemes and he would show you
block him and you block him and you
block him and then he would take Anthony
and his guy and erase him so we know
this guy's taken care of and so he
became the eraser that's exactly when
it's so neat he never had a game plan
yeah because McNally knew that guy was
just going to be erased from the field
just erased him yeah you know when you
think about that - I just his hands when
you see Anthony Monroe's hand just
fingers are not supposed to go in that
certain perpendicular manner you know
and and you take a look at some of these
guys who are here and what they have
left on the field and how what it means
to them
to return here as well I mean it's it's
really something else when you think
about it I said just it's look it's the
history of pro football is what it is
and you watch it through you know the
sixties the seventies the eighties you
know now you've got guys going in there
who played in the in the 2000s so it's
amazing to me because you would think
the guys had a fantastic career and is a
lot to go into the Hall of Fame he would
be I'm not saying he'd be jaded but you
know he would expect to be here but even
when these guys who will definitely be
locks to get in here right away get in
something overtakes him and you can see
the emotion and all of that last night
we had Tony Dungy was in the booth with
us and you just tell me he just sparkles
when he thinks about this thing and and
a lot of these guys would not miss one
year of coming back here and being a
part of this thing a minute it really is
it they exude the specialness of what
this is it's it's very very unique and
it's amazing a guy like Kurt Warner when
you think of the odds I mean try to try
to put together the Vegas odds that Kurt
Warner could have possibly been in the
Hall of Fame it was impossible there's
this guy's stocking shelves and I was
somewhere I am Arena League played in
the arena yeah we were I was messing
around a little bit before but I was
thinking the Arena League made him I
mean think about if you're the
quarterback and you've only got three
offensive lineman in front of all out of
hand
right you getting rid of that football
and now in that way played and now
easier at the Hall of Fame we're going
to take a break when we come back one
more segment we'll talk a little bit
here and now with Al Michaels and Cris
Collinsworth from them
Cris Collinsworth and now Michaels here
for a second segment now a number two
Steve Largent Pro Football Hall of Famer
we're going to pluck him out of the rain
it's Keith luncheon room shortly Sunday
Night Football getting set for yet
another season on NBC and it's pretty
neat there's a there is a Sunday Night
Football
I guess area display display that is
just right around the corner yeah that's
right here we just cut the ribbon
congratulations on that it's very cool
if you know you we heard about it but to
see the way they set it up and then they
you know they roll tape of some of the
great Sunday night games and you know
we've only been on the air for 11 years
but it's amazing when you see some of
these plays roll by and Chris and I are
standing there going wait a minute
remember that we did that we did that
it's it's an amazing compilation and a
lot of folks were coming by you know the
people visiting the Hall of Fame and and
stopping in and watching the tape go by
and enjoying what they did they did a
great job with it so what do you
remember which show it was that so what
the deal is it's six straight years is
the number one primetime show right
which is amazing and for me my favorite
show as a kid growing up was all in the
family
I loved all in the family I thought that
wasn't funny a show I've ever seen in my
life
and Archie Bunker the whole thing and we
had yeah and they were what four
straight years is the number one show I
think they were they were five I think
five yeah whatever what but you know
these your favorite shows kind of thing
growing up American Idol and all these
great shows that had these incredible
runs then now we're tied with the
longest yeah streak so we just can't
screw it up now we got to set the record
is even go I'll go over seven does that
make you the Archie Bunker of this well
I see Norman Lear once in a while and
our favorite restaurant Toscana LA and I
I want to be able to dish in the next
time I see him you know supplant them
you took them down he took down Norman
Norman you're done you're finished it
might be 94 and he looks great but
you're finished so which game I guess
when you saw that out there that are you
I guess most proud of or you think that
stands out Chris these games that you've
been able to be a part of here the last
11 years you know it's funny the one
that popped up
on the screen first when I was watching
it was the fourth and - where the
Patriots decided to go for it on fourth
down basically not wanting to have to
punt the ball back to Peyton Manning on
my own side of the field and any other
coach you would have said what are they
doing but you knew Belichick had a plan
and he had the math behind him and he
had the history and he knew his defense
at that moment we've been watching the
game they weren't going to stop Peyton
Manning and they didn't when they turned
it over either but I just remember and
then there's this great shot that our
guys had a belly check after Peyton
threw the winning touchdown pass taking
his hands and just rubbing him over his
face like wait a minute the computer
malfunctioned on that one or something
you know is just and there are just so
many of those kind of great just shots
those great looks that you have Tom
Brady jumping up and down on the
sideline and the Super Bowl when Malcom
Butler made the interception and there's
those moments you just they define your
life in some way
yeah and that shot of Richard Sherman
looking up in pain a very same moment
where he realizes that the Super Bowl
has just gone down the tubes and in a
way I mean of all the storylines that
we've heard in the last several weeks
and months and richard has even said
this it seems as if Seattle still has
not gotten past that moment that you
guys called that night and that short
yardage situation yeah it's a just to go
back for one second to what Chris was
talking about here we get those shots
because you know you know Fred Goodell
Ian drew us a cup and I've worked with
crew 18 years now Fred 17 that just
doesn't happen
that's all preparation I mean you and
when people can sit at home and watch
the reaction shots I mean that's it you
can't play in every reaction shot but
these guys are so good at knowing where
they might want to be to punch up a shot
and that's why you see things like that
meanwhile with Seattle I mean one of the
more interesting teams to watch this
year obviously because yeah what Richard
is a fascinating guy and I think he's a
as bright as they come in the National
Football League he really sees the whole
the whole picture he's in our meetings
we you know
we love talking bin and he says what he
thinks and you know you get that whole
different kind of dynamic up there but
they have been very successful and you
know you have that moment in the
Superbowl you say can you get past it
well they go to the playoffs the
following year you know get really lucky
on the best kick in Minnesota but it's
still a team to be reckoned with right
now and you know I put them as among the
favorites I would say to you know to
wind up back there again that that was
just a brag of my partner for a minute
though that call was an amazing call by
out because you have to remember Malcom
Butler really was an afterthought in
that game he replaced somebody who was
having a poor game and came in and then
of course the play right beforehand but
I was watching the play not on a monitor
I was watching it live on the field and
I'm a freely admit to the world I didn't
know what happened on that play I saw
the collision but I didn't know who had
the ball and I didn't know exactly what
had happened it was such a bang-bang
kind of play and I was like dude I mean
just had it he just had it from the
moment that it happened and the the the
emotion I can remember and now obviously
was was finishing calling the play and
it seemed like a 30 seconds or a minute
went by and I'm just going through every
scenario in my brain of why the Seattle
Seahawks threw the ball in that
situation and I go I am missing
something there's something I'm not
thinking about here and obviously the
you know Patriots had their goal line
defense and they had their three wide
receivers and then the whole timeout
scenario comes about now why is it
Belichick calling the timeout well he's
got the matchup that he likes so he's
almost forcing them to throw the ball
which is his only chance to here now our
Seattle going to take a timeout in order
to give them a chance to get their goal
line offense on and try and run it in
with I mean there's like a billion
things going through and the only thing
to come out of my mouth is I can't
believe that call
unlike you could have done a little more
analysis than that but that was all my
friend actually it was a little more of
an expletive that was coming out in
there I settled on that yeah I mean you
can that's why they're still talking
about today I mean that moment that you
guys called right there and interesting
also you called the Blair Walsh mist
kick as well right and you want to just
to continue on about how you know how I
feel about your guys broadcast okay that
that shot of the Sun going down and you
saw the silhouettes of people breathing
in that cold air it was something out of
NFL Films here on film to 60 it was
something from Mars it was I think it
was maybe the line that you even you
know I can I remember a Jupiter and it
was another planet and then your
broadcast in terms of every time there's
a penalty and because I think you speak
to fans and the thing that it frustrates
people the most is those third down
illegal contact penalties that are on
the other side of the field or one of
those holding penalties when the ball is
already down the field and you didn't
even see it occur you guys have it it's
every time that there is a penalty
there's a replay of it and Fred Goodell
II and drew as a coffee or producer and
director are top-notch and it's another
reason why I'm excited about Thursday
Night Football being associated with NFL
Network and NBC in terms of the Seattle
Seahawks the NFC is wide open to me the
AFC we're all just assuming rigor you
guys are going to see New England in
Minnesota again unless the Raiders can
come with enough wins to perhaps force
Brady to get on a plane to play an AFC
championship game this year would you
agree with that assessment
you guys you know people are talking
about the Patriots going 16 and OH I
mean that's it's ridiculous to talk
about that at this point 1999 19 low
whatever it would be well you got to
start with 16 before you get to 19 you
know we love sports because you don't
know what's going to happen you just
don't know I mean you want to go back to
2008 what happened to Tom Brady on
opening day in the first quarter out for
the season so Matt Cassel came in he did
a great job went 11 and 5 that team
didn't get to the playoffs I'm not
saying you know you look
for somebody to get hurt but you you
don't know what's going to happen
between now and and February the fourth
of chemical day a fourth or fifth for
the Super Bowl so you just don't hand
them the trophy now are they good of
course they're great it's a great team
great coach great quarterback great a
lot of things there's gotten better but
rich you know just because it looks that
way on paper doesn't necessarily mean it
winds up that way so I think's I mean
it's always going to be an exciting
season tell me a year when everything
worked out according to what you thought
of the beginning the year never you know
what's amazing is that nobody is talking
about the Atlanta Falcons
that's true it's amazing I mean here's a
team that had the the world champs down
28 to 3 and probably but for the fact
their defense had to defend 94 95 plays
completely exhausted completely wore
themselves out everything fell into
place for the New England Patriots that
had to fall into place and yet at
halftime think of what you were thinking
you were thinking is this the end of an
era is this the Patriots they only went
in about half the Super Bowls that
they're in does Brady now give way to
Garoppolo no question is Belichick not
the genius that we have a new era now
with what's going on in Atlanta the
Falcons fans I was there in the stadium
they're taking celebratory pictures with
the field in the background and this
thing in in one half of football the
universe change and now we're talking
about the Patriots going 19 and oh I
can't remember one person having a
legitimate conversation about the
balcony went in the Super Bowl this year
during the entire offseason stream and
because of one half and one overtime
period of football and that's just I
guess the hangover right aspect that
everyone's expecting you'd like I have
and plus the NFC South it always gets
refreshed where somebody from the bottom
finishes on top that might be it and
then there's Dallas so you guys saw
somewhat last night I mean obviously the
starters weren't out there what do you
think of Dallas opportunity to take a
step forward and get Jerry Jones a ring
in the year that he gets his jacket I
like the I like their chances immediate
Prescott he's the real deal I mean I'd
be shocked that that Prescott doesn't
follow it up with at least a pretty good
year or a very good year Elliott we you
know we don't know about him at the
beginning of the season but he led the
league in rushing you know the line is
great
you got Dez Bryant he had some other
pretty good receivers kind of a revamp
defense but probably good enough opening
nights gonna tell us a lot Giants at
Dallas I mean the Giants were the
problem for Dallas last year beat him
twice and here I think you know in a
couple minutes I have left here I do
want to hit Jerry Jones before before
you guys have to go when he took over
that team and it was one of the first
things he did was tell Tom Landry thanks
for the memories and and then the Jimmie
Johnson stuff happened I get to say that
he's in the Pro Football Hall of Fame
now that you think anybody see that
coming I mean Chris when you remember
the way he took over that team and now
here he is going to get his jacket his
bust
well that was arguably one of the
greatest teams ever assembled so yeah I
think you win three Super Bowl
championships in four years and the
trade with Herschel Walker and the
firing of the coach and Jimmie Johnson
coming in and doing all the things that
he did you know the owners going to get
some credit for that and I think
justifiably so
but I think I'm a little bit of his Hall
of Fame has to do with what he's done
for that league the stadium set a new
standard by which we all measure all of
them but he's made more money I feel
fairly safe in saying this he's made
more money with his different way of
looking at the NFL universe that from if
Coke is the sponsor of the NFL then
Pepsi is going to be the sponsor of my
stadium you know that sort of other way
of thinking about it and he always
pushes the envelope he was not going to
settle for taking less from Network
television as the NFL was about to do he
demanded more Fox comes into the picture
he can't take off so there's a big
picture part of this thing but the
Dallas Cowboys does they answer that
question I look at this offense
conceivably conceivably there could be
seven halls Hall of Famers on that
offense those three offensive linemen
all to the Provo every single year Jason
Witten
you can't start better than dak and Zeke
did in their rookie year and Dez who
knows you know you know announcer but
that is a now defensively they dismantle
their secondary they've got all their
suspensions on their defensive line so
the first month of the season let's see
can the defense do what they did last
year just to follow up on what Chris
said in terms of what Jerry has done for
the league he turned the league upside
down in 1995 when he said I don't like
the way the marketing and Merchandising
are going and Park Avenue went crazy and
I was in the middle of that because
Jerry called me that day we're doing the
opening Monday night game Dallas of the
Giants he says I'm going to walk out
under the sidelines with Phil Knight
from Nike and the league had a deal I
think with adidas at the time I can't
remember with who and he did it and it
there was an earthquake on Park Avenue
but he was the guy who saw the
opportunity to multiply increase what
the revenue would be for the National
Football League and along the way too
but he's been a great great showman he's
been terrific I said own last night it's
just it's fun covering him and with the
Dallas Cowboys they are a team that you
love or you detest but you cannot ignore
them it's the Dallas Cowboys when
somebody says to me during the week you
know what's on this week on Sunday night
ago it's the Cowboys oh yeah great it's
the Dallas Cowboys they make him pay
attention and he's known how to to work
that to the nth degree the other thing
about Jerry that people don't know he's
unbelievably philanthropic this guy has
been as charitable as any owner in the
National Football League and does it
fairly quietly too so I mean to me he is
a so deserving of being here thank you
guys for coming appreciate it this is
going to blast really and then tonight
speaking of over-the-top in terms of
entertainment I'm hearing the Jones bash
is going to be insane I'm here at
you tell me how I'm hearing that the the
MC of the gold jacket dinner is going to
do a phenomenal job tonight you get it
we can all get out of there and go to no
pressure no pressure
I'll get you out on time that I don't
worry how Michaels Cris Collinsworth you
guys go back the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy